Truth is sometimes stranger than fiction,
but when it comes to the stars of the History
Channel hit Swamp People, truth is also stranger
than reality television.
Think you know everything there is to know
about these muck dwellers?
Well, think again, because we're about to
reveal what die-hard fans don't even know
about Swamp People.
Gator bait
In May of 2017, former Swamp People star Roger
A. Rivers Jr. was arrested and charged with
20 counts of...well, pretty much everything,
from illegally selling alligator meat to marijuana
possession.
So if you ever thought the cast of Swamp People
must be high to mess around with gators like
that, turns out you were right — at least
when it comes to Roger Rivers
Quick draw
Swamp justice apparently moves a lot quicker
than traditional courts, which is something
the operators of a shrimp boat found out the
hard way after Chase Landry shot at them.
According to the Terrebonne Parish Sheriff's
Office, Landry was in Bayou Chene in September
of 2016 hunting alligators when he fired at
the passing boaters, allegedly shooting a
hole into a "plastic gas can which was on
top of the cabin of the commercial shrimp
boat."
Upon his arrest, Landry claimed "he shot because
the victim refused to slow down and would
have sunk their boat."
At least he played it safe by shooting a gas
can.
What's the worst that could have happened?
"Smile you son of a..."
Five feet high and rising
Just one month before his alleged vigilante
attempt to stop a speeding shrimp boat, Chase
Landry spent five days in and around Baton
Rouge rescuing dozens of people stranded in
high water during the Louisiana Flood of 2016.
Landry told The Times-Picayune, "Seeing everyone
get together and forgetting about what color
we are or what this and that one said — that
was thrown to the wayside and what was important
came out.
… If you see your brother or sister or neighbor
in a bind, you'll help them."
Unless they're speeding in a shrimp boat.
In that case, you know, shoot at the most
explosive thing possible.
Money shot
He may sound like a character from The Waterboy,
but Troy Landry is no fool.
Not only does he operate a successful crawfish
harvesting businesses, he also rakes in the
cash making roughly 230 public appearances
a year thanks to his fame as a reality TV
star.
So what has he done with all that money?
Turns out he's built a dream home on the bayou,
which is entirely made of cypress, and boasts
both an outdoor kitchen and a thousand-square-foot
living room.
Who would've guessed selling stickers featuring
the phrase "Mudda Fricka" could possibly land
you in the lap of luxury?
That shirt
Troy Landry's signature striped polo shirt
has become as much of a staple on Swamp People
as captioned dialogue and dead alligators.
But according to Landry, the shirt holds a
secret, hidden in plain sight under everyone's
noses.
He posted on Facebook, "I know everyone is
wondering why I wear the same shirt?
The answer is: we all do!
Mine just stands out because of the stripes.
It's for editing purposes.
We bought ten of the same shirt."
Just think, if the other cast members had
worn more interesting shirts, they might have
become the star of the show!
Cruelty claims
Over the years, Swamp People has come under
fire from animal rights activists.
The protest site ForceChange.com petitioned
The History Channel to cancel the show, writing,
"Swamp People does nothing to educate people
about history, it only promotes killing.
It is very immoral to air a show that depicts
people torturing and killing animals."
The Louisiana Department of Wildlife and Fisheries,
on the other hand, argues that their program
of "regulated harvest" is actually a conservation
effort.
According to the department's website, "our
sustained use management program provides
direct economic benefit and incentive to private
landowners, and alligator hunters/farmers
who lease land, to protect the alligator and
to protect, maintain, and enhance the alligator's
wetland habitats."
So far, The History Channel seems to be siding
with Swamp People and not the gators — but
who knows what changes the future might bring.
Later, gator!
Swamp People has actually had a measurable
effect on the alligator meat industry.
According to a Miami New Times investigation
of the lucrative black market that deals in
alligator meat and skin, shows like Swamp
People and Gator Boys have "fueled a surge
in prices as alligator meat became a novelty
in restaurants throughout the South.
From 2013 to 2015, the price doubled to $8.75
a pound on the wholesale market, and trappers
couldn't catch enough alligators to meet the
demand."
The Times also reported that alligator skins
sell for "anywhere from $20 to $40 per foot."
That's remarkable, not only because a TV show
could have such a real world effect on a commodity
like that, but also because it means people
are genuinely basing their diet and wardrobe
choices on something called Swamp People.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!